You've been lied to about candlesticks.
Question for you. This is the perfect
buying signal, perfect zone. Is it going
to go up from here?
Is it this pattern or this one or this
one? Order fil. Most traders get it
wrong. Candlesticks only tell half the
story. And if you're relying on them
alone, you're setting yourself up for
failure. I just made over $2,000 on this
trade this morning. And it all started
with this common candlestick pattern
right here. But this indicator right
here is really what confirmed that it
was time to jump into the trade. You
need to use this every time you enter
into a trade. Otherwise, you're likely
to continue creating unnecessary losses.
In this video, I'm going to walk you
through the three simple steps that will
completely change how you approach
trading candlestick patterns. First, I'm
going to show you how to actually read
candlesticks the right way so you stop
misreading signals that were really
never entries in the first place. Then,
I'll break down to you the six most
effective candlestick patterns I found
over the years, ones that I still use
every single week. And finally, I'll
reveal the indicator combo that I use to
filter out fake signals and confirm my
entries with confidence that will stop
you jumping into false signals and
creating more losing drains. If you're
entering a trade every time a setup
appears, you're going to lose money. I
know you probably want to skip ahead to
the indicator that confirms whether a
trade is worth taking or not, but if you
don't build the solid foundation first,
it won't make sense anyway. and worse,
you'll still end up hesitating or
jumping in too early, creating
unnecessary losses. Candlestick patterns
are just as important. And so, let me
show you how to properly read and use
them first. Now, prior to candlestick
charts, we had just simple line charts.
That is essentially just connecting two
dots or more. Now, instead, candlesticks
give us four points of data. And you can
see comparing these two charts, there's
a lot of data down here that you're
missing in the line chart. That's why
candlestick charts are so important.
Candlestick charts give you four points
of data. They give you the closing
price, the opening price, and the
extreme low and high of that
candlestick. A green candlestick
signifies that the price went up over
the candlestick, and a red signifies
that it went down. And then what you
have outside of the body of the
candlestick is you have what's called a
wick. And essentially this just shows
you where the price moved to the extreme
high before it ended up closing or
opening at the price the candlestick
closed at. And then candlesticks can
also represent different time periods.
One candlestick can be changed to
represent any amount of time or volume.
But the idea is that it represents a
certain amount of data. A lot of the
time and most commonly it's a timebased
chart where one candlestick can
represent one minute, 10 minutes, 30
minutes, an hour, a day, a week. And
what this allows you to do is create all
these different patterns in those
different time frames. So even if you
see a pattern on a 1 minute chart, it
may play out a specific move on a one
minute chart, but there could be a
completely different pattern on a 30inut
chart. But all the candlestick patterns
and everything that we're going to go
over can be used on any market or time
frame because what you're doing is
you're reading the candlesticks. And
candlesticks represent the price
movement of that asset you're looking at
and it's essentially the raw data of
where the buyers and sellers are. And so
no matter what you're trading, it's
representing that raw data. And all
these patterns are common indicators of
what that raw data is really telling you
could happen in the market. Now, most
traders know what candlesticks are, but
almost none of them know how to actually
use them correctly. And that's why I'm
building up to the tool that I use to
confirm what really makes a candlestick
pattern a signal and not just noise to
fake you out. Now, make sure to remember
these four key points in the candlestick
because one of the tools that I'm going
to show you later is entirely based on
this data and it's extremely powerful
for helping you confirm candlestick
entries. Now, let's go over some
candlestick anatomy. The first off being
big versus small bodies and what this
means. A big body represents dominance
from either the buyers or sellers. This
green candlestick right here opening
here, moving all the way up here and
closing shows a lot of buying pressure
versus something smaller like this where
the sellers it opens up here, moves down
and closes here is small representing
not that much movement from the sellers.
This is a trade right here where I made
over $2,000. And yeah, this candlestick
right here was a really big clue to jump
in on the trade, but wasn't the overall
reason of why I took this trade. The
real confirmation came from something
else. Something that I'll show you later
that helps me confirm whether a
candlestick pattern is worth entering in
or not. The big candlesticks matter, but
only when they align with the right
signals. Now, the second most important
structure you'll see is candlesticks
with large wicks. This candlestick right
here is showing you a potential for a
reversal because the price of this
candlestick opened up here, pushed up
higher, and then sold off and closed a
tiny bit above where it was. But
essentially, what this candlestick is
telling you is that this overall price
was rejected. And so it could signal a
potential for a reversal. Same thing
with this candlestick. The only
difference is a slight difference in the
open price of the candlestick and the
close price. It's just flipped. And then
this candlestick pattern right here is
the same thing but in reverse where the
price opened up here, pushed a little
higher, sold off hard, but then that
hard selloff there was reversed and it
closed somewhere there. Again, this is
showing you a potential for a reversal
to come in the following candlesticks.
This is why knowing that data versus
just a line chart is extremely
important. Now, these big wicks are
critical for entering into potential
trades. This trade right here, this big
reversal candlestick with a huge wick
was the final confirmation to jump on
this trade that made over $1,000 in just
a few minutes. but only when they appear
in the right context. In a minute, I'm
going to show you how to tell when these
big reversal wicked candlesticks are
actually important and when they're just
making noise trying to trap you. Now,
the last one of these is when there is a
small body and equal wicks on above or
below the body of the candlestick. What
these do is they show classic
indecision. And the whole reason of this
is because for either of these three
candlestick patterns, the price
essentially opened up somewhere in the
middle of the candlestick, pushed one
direction, reversed the other direction,
and then reversed again, closing near
the middle of the candlestick. With this
one right here, it's specifically opened
and closed at the exact same price,
showing no movement. But it's really key
to know that because what this does is
it shows indecision. And these are
called dogeis. But here's the problem.
Dogeis constantly fake people out or
just get them in bad trades. So in a
minute, I'll show you how to read them
correctly and use them to your
advantage. But first, we need to talk
about multi- candlestick patterns. Now,
let's jump into the top six candlestick
patterns I've used over the years. These
are common candlestick patterns that you
will see that based on their structure
and the market psychology of what the
data is showing you commonly will play
out in a specific manner. Now the first
one of these candlestick patterns is
called the engulfing candlestick
pattern. It's just a two candlestick
pattern, but what it signifies is that
it's a reversal pattern where the chart
is coming down. And if you see this
pattern, it will signify that it's
likely that the price reverses to the
upside. The idea of how this works is
you have a bearish candlestick that is
engulfed by a bullish candlestick right
after it where the open of this
candlestick is lower than the low of the
previous candlestick and the close of it
is higher than the high of the bearish
candlestick. The whole idea is it is a
massive reversal happening where it
completely blows out the previous
candlestick. And this can happen on the
flip side for the bearish version too
where a smaller bullish candlestick is
engulfed by a big bearish candlestick.
And again, the idea is that it's a
reversal candlestick and likely the
market is going to reverse after this.
And this is a great confirmation for an
entry just like the trades I showed
earlier. But again, you don't want to
just blindly be using it by itself. The
next one of these patterns is called a
pin bar candlestick. This is where the
important of wicks comes into play. What
this can help us do is it's another
reversal candlestick pattern, but the
idea is that you have a big bullish
candlestick followed by what's called
this reversal candlestick. This large
wick is showing us that the price tried
to continue higher and was rejected.
It's showing you a flip in the momentum
of the market that this is representing.
the price was previously moving higher
and a topping pattern is going to flip
the price of the market and this
candlestick here is showing that and
followed by it to complete this pattern
is a nice bearish reversal candlestick
after this. The idea is that this is
going to reverse lower and it's a
confirmation that you can use to enter
into a trade. Same thing goes for the
bullish version where it's coming down
reversing in a big way and it's
indicating that the market could
continue higher reversing that trend
that it was in. This is how you can
start to read the market like a book.
You can start to use these patterns and
slowly build upon them, connecting them
so you can eventually read a whole stock
chart clearly. This next candlestick
pattern is called a threeline strike
pattern. What it's showing you is there
is a clean methodical uptrend in the
market and then it is broken and
reversed very rapidly by this huge
engulfing candlestick that engulfs
multiple of the candlesticks before it.
It shows you a massive switch in
momentum and a massive increase in
momentum in the other direction. And so
how you can use this is again bullish or
bearish side is that the market is
switching from a slow methodical move
lower to a rapid move higher. Buyers are
really stepping in wanting to buy at
this level which is likely to continue
to push the market higher after this
pattern. Again, these patterns are super
powerful, but you have to stack them
with other indicators now that we can
start to get into some larger patterns.
And a flag pattern is a key pattern that
will help us understand how to read
dogeis. And so, how this pattern works
is it's a continuation pattern. The idea
is the market moves up and goes
sideways. It essentially creates a flag.
The idea with this is the market's had a
really strong move higher and it's now
just taking a breather. It's coming to a
point where it just needs to catch its
breath. It's a little overextended and
this pattern often signifies a
continuation that it could continue
higher. That this momentum that it had
before is just taking a pause and it's
going to come back in and push the
market higher. But what will often
happen is you'll start to see dogeis
here when it flags out. And dogeis are
okay if there's a couple of them, but
once there becomes too many, you can
start to get trapped. If we flip over to
the bearish version here, it's the same
thing to the flip side where we have a
strong momentum to the downside, but
then it starts to go sideways. And the
key to knowing if this is really going
to continue or it could do what I call a
failed breakout where it attempts to
break lower and the market actually
reverses trapping people and making this
pattern cause a false signal is when you
start to get a lot of dogeis stacking
up. When you start to see the market
just sit there for too long, that's when
the momentum has really just dried up
and it's not taking a brief break. The
idea with this pattern is it has a large
momentum move and it just takes a quick
break before it continues higher. If it
starts to take too long of a break like
this, that's when you want to stay out.
That's when the dogeis can really start
to give you some insight that there is
too much indecision in the market and
it's likely to not have a clear move in
either direction that is easy to trade
and you should stay out of the market. I
used to fall for this all the time
myself. This pattern right here looks
really clean, right? But this can easily
turn into what I call a failed breakout
where the market pushes lower and then
immediately flips on you reversing
higher. There's one key missing step
that is really good to know to tell the
difference between if it's actually
going to break out or do a fake out. And
we're almost to where we can talk about
that, but I want to first talk about a
few big picture candlestick patterns
that are really going to tie this all
together for you. The first one of those
is a pullback pattern. This is a super
simple market structure pattern, but
it'll start to connect some of these
dots for you. The whole idea with this
is here's the bearish version, which
means the market's going to reverse is
the market's coming up in a nice solid
trend higher. It pulls back and then it
pushes one more time up. But then what
happens is, you'll notice we get an
engulfing candlestick pattern right
here. And what that signals is it's
putting in a lower high right here. This
swing, if you kind of just think about
it like a line chart now, is the market
made a high here, pulled back, made one
more high here, and now is pushing
lower. That high is lower than this one.
And in the big picture structure idea of
the market, that is a big reversal
signal. If you couple it with this
engulfing candlestick pattern, this
starts to become a powerful signal. As
soon as this engulfing candlestick
pattern here is formed, you can use that
as a confirmation to enter in on a trade
with the idea that the market is going
to push lower based off of that. Same
thing goes for the bullish side, but you
can see on the flip side, same thing,
but you could have a different
candlestick pattern, making this, you
know, you can even call it a double
bottom. This is how you start to look at
candlesticks and create larger picture
structures in the market that can signal
key areas that you want to pay attention
to. So, you can start to see this
pattern and the flag pattern are very
similar in a lot of ways. How do you
know when a pattern is going to either
continue or when it's going to fake you
out in the opposite direction in
reverse? Which is why in a minute we're
going to go over how do you know when
it's actually the right time to jump
into a trade versus when it's important
to stay out so you don't actually get
trapped and lose money. Now, before we
go further, if you want a downloadable
guide that goes through all of these
candlestick patterns, I've created a
free 14page PDF that you can download
for free in the description of this
video, and it will go into way more
patterns with way more detail that I
highly recommend you get. You can
download it in the description of this
video or via this QR code. Now, the last
one of these is called the head and
shoulders pattern. It's a big key
reversal pattern, but again, it's really
powerful when you couple it with the
indicators that really confirm whether
an area is worth taking a trade or not.
The whole idea of how this works is it's
looking at the big picture structure of
the market. It's essentially looking at
the swings of the market where it's
making a in an uptrend. It's making
higher highs and higher lows
consistently and then all of a sudden it
switches to making lower lows and then
lower highs. What you'll start to notice
about these patterns is that they're
very simple. You do not need complex
patterns to understand what the market
is doing. And keys with this head and
shoulders pattern is on the bullish side
where this is going to signal, you know,
we're going to make a reversal to the
upside. This key is you want this final
extreme low that it makes to be strong
and then it to reverse quickly.
Essentially, it's showing you the market
got overextended, accelerated to this
side, and then buyers came in in a big
way, and pushed it to the upside. This
final pullback here, and really adding
this pullback pattern that we talked
about earlier, essentially what it's
doing is it's showing you, it's giving
you the confirmation of, okay, is this
going to just continue lower? Because,
well, it could just continue making
lower lows and lower highs here. But
once it creates this bottom here and
really starts to form this candle and
this candle, that's when you can
confidently say that okay, it's starting
to shift. And that's how you use these
patterns to understand what the market
is going to do. Okay, now we can get to
the indicators that separate the false
signals from the real ones. These are
the two key tools that I use to confirm
if a candlestick pattern is really worth
following. Without this, you're probably
just flipping a coin following these
candlestick patterns. Now, if you don't
have access to high quality trading
charts like this, I use Ninja Trader for
all my chart analysis and trading. It's
what I rely on to spot these candlestick
patterns clearly. You can check it out
for free via this QR code or in the
description of this video. Now, the
first one of these is taking into
account the big picture context of the
market. And the way I do that is look at
the key swings that the market is
having. It may seem really simple, but
the way I do this has a trick to it. And
so what you want to be doing is you want
to be looking at the key areas and
extremes where the market is reversing
either on the upper end of where it
keeps bouncing or on the lower end. You
can see the extremes of the market make
it way more likely for it to reverse.
Because if you try and capture every
single move in the market, all these
little reversals in here, it's really
hard to know what the market's going to
do at that point. But if you wait for
the market to become come up to a point
where it's overextended,
it hits an area where it's previously
bounced and reversed off of multiple
times. It makes it way more likely to do
that again. It's essentially telling you
that it's at an overextended location
and it likely will reverse to the
downside. This can happen on the flip
side as well. And another tool you can
use is actually a trend line for this.
You can see here if I try and just draw
a zone, it kind of works, but it it's
not really bouncing off of that zone.
Instead, it's bouncing off of this trend
line that I can draw off of these two
swings. This one again, and you can see
here, it came and bounced off of this a
fourth time after it made an extreme
move to the downside. And I've actually
created an indicator in Ninja Trader
that will draw these key reversal zones
for you. And so as a beginner, when
you're just getting used to
understanding where the key areas in the
market are to pay attention to, this
indicator will drastically help you pay
attention to the right resistance and
support zones that make it way more
likely for you to know where to bet the
market is going to go a certain
direction. And you can download that for
free in the description of the video as
well. And the last most important thing
here is this indicator that helps you
identify when the market is overextended
to one direction making it likely to
reverse back the other direction in a
big way. This indicator draws these
green or red lines based on if the
market is overextended. And so how you
can use this is coupling it with
candlestick patterns, bigger trend lines
or support or resistance zones. And it's
so it's likely that if you combine this
with a market being pushed up, you're at
a resistance level and it pushes back
lower, the market will reverse in that
other direction. And you can see here
all these green lines that it has saying
that it's overextended. The market
pushed all the way back giving all this
move back up. And so if you're able to
capture that move, that would be a
massive reversal. Same thing on the flip
side. It said, "Okay, it's super
overextended to the downside. It needs
to switch back to the upside." Took a
little while, but eventually reversed
this whole move back up. And now
currently right now where the market is
today it had a big move up. This said it
was overextended reversed back lower and
now it's making another push higher
showing that it's overextended and it's
actually coming into this really big
picture trend line right here. This
upwards resistance zone where it's
likely to shift lower. And so what I'm
going to do now is I'm going to sit and
watch this and wait to see if I get a
candlestick formation forming. And so
you can get this indicator in the
description below this video as well for
free. I highly recommend getting it. It
will really help you drastically know
when you're in a key area of
opportunity. Otherwise, it's really
likely that you won't know when you're
in a good spot and you're likely to get
in a bad signal that it's going to lose.
And so, if I pull up that trade where I
made $2,000 in one swing, let's answer
our last few questions. Now, this is
where everything comes together. And
you'll see why here in a second. So, the
first thing is I'm looking for those two
big key indicators. One is this market
has come up to this resistance zone and
then it's come up very quickly. I don't
have that indicator that shows you that
it's overextended here with those lines
to the and bars to the side, but you can
pretty much see here that that's what's
going on. It's moved up quickly. So,
it's overextended in one direction. And
so what we want to do is how we wait and
figure out if this is going to be a
breakout or a failed breakout is a lot
of the times is you can wait and see
what the pullback does. This breaks out
of the previous major swing high that
the market had before. And so a lot of
times people might jump in thinking that
that's going to be a breakout and
instead it fakes them out. And so the
way to know if that's going to happen is
if the market is overextended into that
level. The market likes to move in clean
methodical movements. And if instead it
comes up clean, methodical and then
shoots up into this level like this like
it's done here is it's way more likely
to cause a fake out and reverse back
lower. And so that's the key to knowing
if something's more likely to do a
failed breakout or actually break out
and continue higher. And then the last
thing here is once it does that fake
out, what I'm looking for is that
pullback pattern to happen. That's kind
of where you start to zoom in and figure
out, okay, where do I actually want to
enter in on this trade? And what did
that for me was seeing that it
essentially had an engulfing pattern
here, pushed lower, and then it had a
pullback pattern here where the market
tried to go higher. But you can see this
wick right here where the market pushed
up and closed lower with a bearish
candlestick. And then after that
candlestick, it had a massive bearish
candlestick. And when that one closed, I
put in an order right below that
candlestick to bet that the market was
going to go lower. And then I put my
stop loss initially above this swing
high here because I think that I want to
give the market room to play out, but if
it comes all the way up here, it could
continue to keep going lower. Sometimes
the market goes down really quickly like
this. Sometimes it has to play around a
little while. And so that's how you know
if a candlestick is just noise or it's
an actual entry signal is when you start
to you look at the big picture and then
you start to zoom in slowly. You only
want to use it as the final confirmation
to jump in. You don't want to just
randomly be looking for big candlesticks
or candlestick patterns in the middle of
a move. You want to be looking at them
at the extremes. And then from there,
the market moved very quickly and easily
in my direction, and I was able to close
out with a big profit. And so, make sure
to get that free 14-page candlestick PDF
guide in the description below. And as
well, you'll find those free custom
indicator tools down there as well. And
if you really want to learn more about
this strategy that I've briefly touched
on and how I use these patterns to
consistently execute trades, what time
frames I use, what charts I actually
trade on, check out this full course
right here where I go step by step
through everything you need to know.
It'll build on this foundation that you
have started to learn already.